that's a that's a poster ship it i'd
watch it i'd go to the
cinemas once they opened again i'm
sending this to the social team please
do
hey everybody welcome to potato mode the
show where we take your favorite games
and turn them into mush we start by
showing how good the game looks
and then we turn the graphics down as
low as we can get them
and then we get real weird with it i'm
here once again with
ben janka hi john luke how's it going uh
pretty good
i'm checking out death stranding on the
pc
here oh one of my favorite games from
that year
oh bb just gave me a like oh that's
excellent thank you bbs they knew that
we started the video
they're ready yes so this is death
stranding on the pc
uh the first of well not the first but
uh a string of playstation exclusives
coming to pc here
which is excellent for us because that
means we can potato fight the
[ __ ] out of it i'm so excited especially
for this one
i i really really like dust stranding
yeah it's a great game next to judgment
probably my favorite game that came out
that year last year seemed so long ago
god this game looks so good on the pc
though it looks really good on the pc
like i'm just the 60 fps obviously
is is a thing that we're looking at but
man everything already looked kind of
photorealistic
like on the playstation 4 pro but it
just
this looks even better let's get up
close to that that boy
nope nope look at this norman reedus
yeah yeah that's i feel that that's a
mood
definitely that's the mood of 2020. oh
yeah
you could also make it so his eyes are
always following the camera and it's
stop looking at me this is more
more norman's reedus than i think i need
it
[Laughter]
oh you got this
am i not doing it right oh he that's a
it's a counter
oh
it's right before he he goes to hit yeah
there we go yeah and then you tie him up
yeah there we go you remember the basics
of cqc
get on the ground what do we got all
right
we got to get this printer printer
interface and we got some extra stuff we
could pick up
oh god that that's always the gamble
that's the death stranding way
are you gonna take these these mediums
and smalls with you i think you could do
it
is that the half-life symbol that is
that's the lambda
thank you
if we get this to 1300 likes they'll
announce half-life 3.
so now that we've made a
high quality delivery on a high quality
setting
are we are we lowering the settings now
yes let's go take a look at what uh our
settings have to offer
all right okay so there actually are not
that
many graphic settings it's pretty it's
pretty limited so
um for starters resolution you can only
really
change in like the kind of most like
basic resolution integers so i can go to
1080p or i can go down to 720 and that's
the lowest i can get huh
we messed up the frame rate vsync which
we're not really going to touch uh and
then graphics quality we could set
uh very low so model detail low memory
for streaming low
uh shadow low oculum occlusion soft uh
save space and then here's some a couple
of post-processing effects which we just
have off as well
depth of field and motion blurs off
however depth of field still applies to
cut scenes
it's only depth of field for um the
in-game stuff so let's just take a look
at how
let's see where we are we can we can
make this look
it's you can see some some kind of
kind of jaggedness around some of the
edges now
oh yeah yeah without any anti-aliasing
on it definitely looks pretty jaggy
it still looks pretty okay though i mean
you get a lot of shimmering
on stuff right there but
otherwise i mean it's it's certainly
playable it's not bad
yeah that's that's kind of
kind of wild like even the the ground
definitely like there's there's a little
bit less
the grass really stands out i guess yeah
is kind of what i'm saying uh
but you know here on potato mode we
always go
even lower exactly this won't do
what hold on
what what is i have so many questions
and i know i'm gonna get so few answers
i have no answers for you
what is why why is there like the gran
why is the grass off the ground
[Laughter]
what happened i have sam porter there's
just so much detail missing he looks
he looks sick what are what are the
things in the sky
what is happening so
over to the side like what is that
coming out of the the mountains
i have no idea to be honest uh
if if you would indulge me for a sec
actually i want to go into the
the settings here because actually when
i tested this i
i had the lighting turned on all the way
and that actually
created a a different effect oh no
please take me there
oh my god
[Laughter]
this is the lighting becomes insanely
harsh
this it looks like it looks like a
really old like
tech demo for something where they
wanted to show real-time lighting
and i love it
like i i really really love it also i'm
still trying to wrap my mind around what
the heck is happening off in the
distance in those mountains
oh no what is what does bb look like
that's a good question will you even be
able to see bb i think you got to turn
on a pose oh you can
you can actually weirdly not that
different yeah
what kind of expression oh no
oh let's just zoom in on i can't really
zoom in unfortunately he kind of
disappears
yeah that's fine so i didn't need to get
too close to that
that's not it at all
yeah i'm gonna see that in my nightmare
anyway i'm on installing death stranding
right now on pc i don't need this
that's a that's a poster ship it i'd
watch it i'd go to the
cinemas once they opened again i'm
sending this to the social team please
do
okay so this is all these are all just
just cool i'm waiting for the the part
where it just harsh
shifts from this
these beautiful landscape shots into
just
the busted up potato fight version of
the game
okay come on it's come on when you cut
when you cut into the real game
i need to see that real death stranding
oh
there it is oh just like that the game
woke up
what is with the stuff in the in the sky
i feel like we're we're exposing like uh
oh all those smudgy birds
yeah i'd crash my bike too if i ran into
someone without any textures loaded on
them
i can't even see what is that
well my bike fell into the ground that's
fair all right here we are
ah this is the death strand then i don't
even know where
hold on you have to jump off uh i need
to see the scene
you need to jump off yo okay
i don't even i didn't even know about
this
there's still stuff way over there yeah
you and then it does the does the thing
when you go back to your
your body
whoa look at this i like i like
the look of this place in potato mode uh
oh my god let's try to not say
specific things yeah that's what i'm
talking about
oh that was horrifying exactly
oh boy
where there once was ground there is not
ground where there should be ground
there is also not ground good luck
that's really unsettling
oh he's so smooth he's so shiny
and we can't even see that his skin is
aging right now
oh his beard looks really like i don't
like her yeah
this this loopy reedus
i'm into that
oh let's not do that
oh my god we should also see his ears
through his hair yeah you can kind of
see his eyeballs too a little bit
yeah precious my photo block of me tie
oh okay uh
everything is gone uh i don't know
how to get down hang to the right
just keep going that way there you go
oh it just flattened everything why
would it
ben i'm scared you've got this what
we'll have then we've got this ben
i'm scared okay oh my god we're
underneath the floor
believe in the me that believes in you
we've just gone down a
a layer yeah there you go and then down
this way
oh how good that waterfall looks though
it's not moving it's like it's stopped
in time
the just everything slightly elevated is
is
too much for me what if this is what the
death stranding did
it's just you know i'd buy it
i know that you're like 30 feet away
from delivering this cargo but that
stack has given me anxiety
mama oh no
oh this guy doesn't even get hair oh he
doesn't
was he bald before no shoot
oh there it is
if you look at this big blue square
you'll see exactly where we're headed
i'm still amazed at the fact that the
tears show up even through potato mode
oh the baby eyes
i didn't i wasn't prepared for the baby
eyes
well the world was different when i was
a kid
yeah oh really gonna say it was also
different when i was a kid
why why are they wow what are those
i i hope i hope someone somewhere
knows enough about game development to
be like oh those are
game stratospheres we make them
to make it easier to separate things or
something
i want i need i need an explanation
oh look at all those textureless crabs
um wonderful
we're getting all these squares on the
screen the pixel reign is my favorite
thing
next to the oh my what dude look at the
the squares so close
i want to know what it is so badly oh i
want to see him uh
t-h grow old or a joke
oh yeah you can kind of see it a little
bit yeah a little bit
shut up you can't even see his face
oh his hair is white now
oh how's it gonna melt wait game i can't
i can't see game
no add some of that that gold does pop
[Music]
[Applause]
off
god i can't take the baby
it's really hard to see anything in this
if i hadn't already played this game i
would think that this is also glitched
yeah
well there it is man oh man
doesn't really look that different yeah
oh what's the beach look like these are
the questions
and we're gonna get these answers ah
man that's fair
but dang it is kind of a weird thing to
go from like what we were just looking
at to this
uh yeah it's like a really big just like
hey yo this is what it could look like
this is what it's supposed to look like
but you guys messed up and you made it
not look like that
there we go oh it dropped right back
into the potato mode oh jeez
[Laughter]
i don't like it he looks worse
underwater
what show me that baby
but
yeah the baby's eyes might be the worst
case thing
ah man i guess that makes sense too i
was really hoping to see some mads
mickelson yeah
oh you're awake oh show me that man here
he is
how does it feel to be back in the world
of the
don't worry i'm a doctor it's unsettling
but he doesn't look
as bad as i thought he would oh
no i've got bad news john luke what
in our our quest for potato mode power
we've removed
the labels from the monster energy can
drinks
oh no he may have made it out of this
maybe the best so far yeah
yeah so why is he got like the weird no
wonder you were out there uh
dots but then dead man doesn't man
maybe there's something going on with
him
what if dead man is actually dead and he
it's a secret spoiler
because his his face is a different face
oh yeah remember how sam can double jump
i love that so much i'm gonna be real
bummed if the president's meeting is all
pre-rendered yeah big same
i i don't think i don't think it it
can't be
oh that's so weird yeah
it's just his face what's it been sam
ten years
look at us a bunch of deathless freaks
meeting like this
oh that has taken on a whole new meaning
oh every time he walks through the
window yeah the window just makes
everything
except for his mouth his mouth is uh
it's pretty alright
oh she's see through two
well i guess dead man's also kind of
see-through depending on the light
but he doesn't have that weird
checkerboarding yeah
bridget you're the president of jack oh
snap
kiss me every time
i blow his eyes and his teeth
why are they there i see you kept this
blank piece of paper around
what do you think it's a picture of
photoshop something in
let us know
there's nothing about this the music
it's such a good dramatic uh moment yeah
it's ruined by all the grass texture
being in the sky
kojima's vision finally realized on the
pc
it's all here i can't wait to see what
type of mods people come out with
minus the hair and the eyes i'm actually
kind of into the weird like
like just
me like matte color palette almost me
too
going on i like it
oh you're gonna walk right into them
nope
oh they aren't affected very much by it
oh i like how it's shiny
oh
yo whale time or dolphin time
ah oh god
yeah that that's
quick real quick use your double jump
norman reedus
double jump to safety
nope nope oh no bb stress levels
increasing
oh no we got this bb
dude go punch that dolphin
mess them up i don't like this bb
stressed out
you're stressed out
so i don't know if that does the
explosion though
but we'll we'll see i don't know i don't
think it does it in the first
area i think you do but i think it has
to
like you have to come in contact with
its like insides by getting eaten
or something it's been a while it's been
a while
what up bb oh no
we're just collecting all the different
bb scenes at this point
oh our hair
everything just definitely go clean
clean him up
yeah he's even telling you hey man i
really gotta
look just let let me please
let me see that butt oh there we go
he's it was like an agent 47 there for a
second
there it is we got it get that that
sweet ad
keep it so there see if we've removed
all of the advertising from this video
game
it's actually a lot more funny when you
don't see the ad
dude people could probably mod in their
own ads
that's what i'm excited for man i want
i want ride with norman reedus to get
replaced with uh like a hatsune miku
thing and then i want miku music to play
while you're pooping
look at that baby oh no
just it's a is a demon all right
everybody well that has been this
episode of potato mode
i hope you had a good time watching it's
a big same because i i definitely had a
fun time
seeing this game through an entirely new
lens well if you enjoyed this episode of
potato mode uh
let us know in the comments below uh
what you would want to see for the next
episode of potato mode
uh what other game we could possibly
just
completely destroy i feel like horizon's
on the horizon
that's a good one that is a good one
we'll probably we'll probably do that
but uh yeah until next time
see ya bye
miss deliver all the packages build
bridges form connections